we're told to fill in the blanks to
complete the equation that describes the
diagram so let's think about what's
going on over here so if we start at 0
and we are we move 1 2 3 4 spaces to the
right of 0 this arrow right over here
represents positive 4 we already see
that right over here in the equation and
then from positive 4 from the tip of
this arrow we then go 1 2 3 4 5 6 spaces
to the left so what we just did here is
we just added a negative 6 to the
positive 4 positive 4 plus negative 6
and where does that put us well we see
it puts us one two spaces to the left of
zero and each of these spaces in this
diagram are 1 so 2 spaces to the left of
0 is going to be negative 2 this is fun
let's keep doing more examples write an
addition equation or subtraction
equation your choice so they're giving
us some choice to describe the diagram
all right let's see was thinking what's
going on here ok we're starting at 0 and
we're going 1 2 3 4 to the left so if
we're going 4 to the left or so we could
say negative 4 negative 4 and then we
and then we're going to go another 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 to the left so we could
write this as negative 4 minus 9 is
equal to and when you go 4 to the left
and then you go another 9 to the left
you end up 13 to the left of 0 which is
negative 13 equals negative 13 so this
way I've written it as a subtraction
equation I guess you could say negative
4 minus 9 is equal to negative 13 now
another way I could have done it I could
have said negative 4 plus I could have
said negative 4 plus negative 9 is equal
to negative 13 as well either of those
would have been legitimate now I've
written it as an addition equation
let's keep going fill in the blanks to
complete the equation that describes the
diagram so we're starting at zero we go
three to the left of zero that's
negative three and then we go another
three to the left of that so we're going
to add another negative three we're
going to add another negative three and
that puts us six to the left of zero
well six to the left of zero is negative
six and we're done